welcome to this video playing civ are
they out 12 so I'm going to go for CC on
keto here see what happens yeah he's
going for the quadruple fianchetto that
i recently had in again against various
a little back
yeah I only have Quincy Julian we're
going to trade the trade all the bishops
only have night ok yeah what one point
is that i can always use be five years
for my nights se6 is tough to play for
black let's just we can do six a bit too
much keep going h4 here trying to
provoke age 5 i'm not really is
threatening age 5 ok and it does not
react to it well I might not threaten it
but I can still play it I mean it so I
mean what I'm trying to say is it's not
so bad that I cannot play it it's not a
huge threat objective hmm what about h6
set an idea I wonder then 95 is a bit
awkward let's see that's interesting
it takes Knight takes you see getting to
that poem on age 67 this is a lesser
danger the pawn might get lost somehow
now that that's really possible how to
do that look d44 something like that
maybe let's get the rope in the game
Queen h3 and take on yourself so it
cannot move to clean easily and look
before is a bit of an issue and I mean
okay maybe you place me five simply five
looking for Nessie five that it doesn't
really do all that much probably I
should break the Queen over them it also
covers the pawn for the moment if i take
f6 is that dangerous route 66 then for
loop d7 95 96 yes and that probably
doesn't work then it looks quite quite
awkward bill
I can go here maybe now if five doesn't
work if he takes I can take with the
Queen that keeps impassive I can check
in on what's going on down okay so
creeped on the trefoil you know this is
an awkward pin should you find a former
probably square root 3 5 or what is he
doing yeah probably going to get
something delivered soonish what is the
the truck outside okay yeah so and you
too now you go up here no yeah do it so
don't know it's good it's good it's good
ibook g3 replace look g8 trading one
book is definitely going to help
especially 8sh seven is totally
overloaded
f3 may be trading this is probably
enough and upset let's win the queenside
not allow not let's not allow that c4
pond to be captured
no opening it up should be good
something like this 45 or a for stuff
Queen g5 is also a threat okay large a
pleasure it was the dot I'm just going
to pause this real quickly ok so now
let's let's have a look at this I wasn't
really sudden the relevant energy
allowed the capture on his heavens i
mean i felt quite happy about the
position but it certainly wasn't
anything special so here ya engine does
Luke d3 instead of root deform yeah and
then makes sense look III and so on is
probably a bit more flexible now I was
bringing the Queen over and here i was
expecting him to take the n and then
this it looks a tad uncomfortable for
black but I'm not entering any time soon
and he have maybe rupee a Droog 35 and I
mean without minor pieces i don't think
i have CNF all that much him i think he
just made a med blunder there overlooked
something maybe you wanted to take first
and lack the king or something yeah yeah
I'm just winning and probably I coulda
done quicker yet I felt I didn't didn't
spoil anything and with the with the
route traded at least there was no
counter play against my king does this
work I think
quite good now i'm having like a 585
couldn t for many i can go back injury
to f4 and move with move move this
forward he basically and we cannot move
the night as well as c5 is hanging so
he's very much limited in his movement
sometimes the Queen against ruined my
nap is not so easy bhatia the position
just looks completely lost ok guys
thanks for watching